[Music]
that's a dress was the selection process
like tell me one secret about it
it was the second dress I tried on and I
just I feel like I'm gonna do that all
night because I've always wondered wear
a cape I feel like a quasi superhero in
it you're on a show where you guys have
turned into kind of superheroes the the
superheroes of this country and what is
it like did you have any idea that it
was gonna be received like this talking
about it I mean we made the pilot this
time last year and ten episodes in for
the show to have been embraced in the
way that it has by people and how much
it means to people it's just it's
overwhelming a lot of people are talking
about Tuesday because there's a big
thing going on Tuesday is Tobey alive or
dead here on the red carpet so Chris the
actor is alive but it's Toby ally you've
waited five weeks I think you can wait a
couple more days what is it like when a
show as big as yours especially kills
off someone that is a love and they've
invested so much time in ie came at
Thrones and other shows with the
trajectory of our show I mean of course
people know that Milo's character jack
is not alive in the present day so I
think it's gonna take a while for things
to sort of shake out and for those
puzzle pieces to sort of fit together
but it's such a unique way of
storytelling and how to be a part of it
all right and we were also we've been
talking with everybody about all this
damn crying that happens on your show
everybody cries everybody cry we write
you do you oh my gosh we cry reading the
scripts we cry on table reads we cry
obviously while we're shooting it's yeah
it's not lost on us either I cry when I
watch the episodes cuz there's so much
that I don't see okay cuz it's so hard
being you know a guy and you're sitting
there and you're crying and you don't
want to look at your wife over and be
like oh I'm crying I guarantee your wife
is like I like that my man is sensitive
and feels his feelings and is connected
to his emotions I I think that's
attractive
clearly it's okay to cry guys
[Music]
you